hey youtubers it's Charlie so they just
confirmed a whole bunch of stuff about
the Harley Quinn movie that they're
making so I'm gonna explain what's going
on
Gotham City sirens from the comics in
what Batman's involvement is going to be
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway going on now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alert so that you
don't miss out on anything so what's
going on we all knew that they were
going to make a Harley Quinn movie
instead of doing a direct Suicide Squad
sequel so right off the bat there were
just like a couple really easy things
that you could take away from that one
they would probably find a way to work
the Joker in just because there was so
much of them together in Suicide Squad
whatever your opinion is about Jared
Leto's performance as the Joker they
kind of come as a pair would you die for
me
yes that's too easy
were you would you live like you can
make a movie that's just about Harley
Quinn she's the main character but the
Joker just so important to who her
character is that you have to include
him in some way
just like you have to include Batman so
even if they didn't originally intend to
do a lot of Batman in the movie he is
definitely going to be in there because
I know Gotham City sirens the title kind
of gives it away but I'll explain that
in a second too because there were a
couple different iterations of the movie
before they confirmed Gotham City sirens
which is basically a Harley Quinn
team-up but nothing happens in Gotham
City without Batman knowing about it
it's not like he went to the beach at
the mascara to just hang out with the
Amazons for a couple months so Harley
Quinn having a damn good time in Gotham
City at the expense of Bruce Wayne and
the bat can I come in here and tell me
that don't get too scared come on and
boy I poured play with you you put five
of my guards in the hospital honey no
one's gonna play with you you sleep on
the ground I said where I want when I
run with who I won so there were a
couple different versions of the movie
when they first announced it first they
talked about a Harley Quinn team up
movie that could have been anything so
we all just kind of thought Gotham City
sirens that was the easy slam dunk but
then later they were talking about
Harley Quinn and the birds of prey which
is a very different type of movie
because even though Harley Quinn has
been featured in birds-of-prey comics
that's really like a superhero team-up
not a villain team-up like Gotham City
sirens so if you never read the comics
way back before the new 52 like pre 2011
there was a title with Catwoman poison
ivy in Harley Quinn they called it
Gotham City sirens it was all about
their friendship their adventures their
relationship just trying to get by as
criminals in and around Gotham City with
all these other external forces swirling
around them you have the other villains
like the Joker who won't leave Harley
Quinn alone then you have people like
Batman that keeps trying to thwart them
when they try to rob people robbed banks
robbed jewelry stores so it's kind of
like a supervillain Thelma and Louise
situation
whereby now they have the opportunity to
introduce the Catwoman character and
poison ivy into this DC extended
universe which is really important for a
number of reasons because they just
bumped the second Justice League movie
to make room for Ben Affleck's Batman
movie which is still on track but now
they have the opportunity to introduce
some really cool Batman characters that
they can later use in that Batman movie
without having to over explain them
again so one of the common problems with
superhero movies team-ups in general is
that there are too many characters for
you to develop really well so you wind
up with a bunch of characters that you
just don't care about so they introduce
say like a Catwoman character in this
Harlequin movie she gets a really nice
arc she becomes much more meaningful
when you see her pop back up during the
Batman movie later on so it should come
as no surprise to anyone that Batman is
still a cornerstone of all DC movies
Superman is one of the biggest comic
book characters of all time but from a
movie standpoint Batman has been much
more successful recently so a lot of
DC's extended movie universe plans are
tied to Batman's success so Ben Affleck
was a great version of Batman Margot
Robbie was a great version of Harley
Quinn so you guys can let me know what
you think about them pulling some of the
movie universe in their direction I feel
like it's good but a lot of it just
depends on what the story the movie is
going to be what is Harley Quinn
Catwoman poison ivy going to be teaming
up for like what's the whole reason for
them to be together what's the conflict
is she fighting with the Joker is she
fighting with Batman is she trying to
steal something is it going to be a big
heist movie is it going to be like
Ocean's eleven with a couple of DC comic
book villains so what they should
probably do is just borrow a little bit
from the beginnings of the team in the
comics so if you're not familiar with
the Gotham City sirens comic book so
what happens is is Catwoman poison ivy
and Harley Quinn are all laid low
they're all sort of on the outs with
their respective male characters
Catwoman and Batman are at odds Harley
Quinn is at odds with the Joker and they
find that poison ivy has seduced and
tricked the Riddler to use his apartment
as her new base of operations so they
all come together form an alliance they
decided they're stronger together and
then go on to have a series of
crime-fighting adventures of their own
like they try to do good but
villains so a lot of times there are
hilarious consequences then eventually
like their loyalty to each other is
tested by people like the Joker like
Harley Quinn thinks about getting back
with him so she ends up betraying the
team so you can see how it's a story
that tests their humanity their loyalty
to each other versus their loyalty to
their own original teams like even
though Catwoman cares about Batman and
he cares about her she's a criminal so
they're always going to be at odds so I
just feel like they're giving margot
robbie the chance to build her character
out like a more fully formed Harley
Quinn we saw a little bit of her in
Suicide Squad we kind of saw her origin
story but they didn't do a really good
job of spelling out how she feels about
the Joker like it's very complicated so
it's really hard to deal with unless you
get your own movie which they're doing
now so what they might do if they want
to keep the character count from
spilling out of control is they'll just
put Batman in the Joker in in addition
to the core Gotham City sirens so you
have Harley Quinn Catwoman and poison
ivy teaming up to fight the Joker but
then you also have Batman that's trying
to arrest them too
so it's really the girls against the two
dudes which I feel like would make for a
really awesome movie but they haven't
said anything about what the actual
story is going to be so it's all
speculation you guys can let me know
what do you want them to do and who do
you want them to fight because there has
to be a reason for them to come together
there has to be an evil antagonist and
then there has to be the Batman
antagonist that's really the only thing
you can count on is that no matter what
they do
Batman will try to arrest them by the
end of the movie the next big thing you
guys have been wondering about they
confirmed David Ayer is going to be
directing it so half of you are probably
like wTF is up with that the other half
were probably like okay sure so what I
think is going on is that he made a
really solid Suicide Squad movie but
when the studio saw it they thought the
audience would respond to something a
little bit lighter so you had all that
drama within trying to cut the two
different versions of the film and merge
them and make something that turned into
a bit of a jumbled mess so I feel like
they're confident in his ability as a
filmmaker like he can make good movies
is just that they need more time to
write the script David Ayer reportedly
only had about six weeks to write The
Suicide Squad script so that was one of
the biggest problems just not having a
real script that was ready and to have
a very clear idea about what the film is
going to be given the reaction to all
the DC stuff during 2016 Batman V
Superman Suicide Squad I feel like they
have a much better idea for the target
that they want to hit and because the
main lead is going to be Harley Quinn
the tone of the film will flow from her
so if you want a good barometer for what
the film is gonna feel like just
re-watch all of Harley Quinn's Suicide
Squad scenes they actually just released
the extended version of the DVD so there
are more Joker Harley Quinn scenes to do
a slightly better job of characterizing
their relationship which is incredibly
codependent and unhealthy oh I'm not
gonna kill you I'm just gonna hurt you
really really bad you think so
well I can take it I wouldn't want you
to break those perfect porcelain cap
teeth when the juice it's your brain
they became the king queen of Gotham
City so given that I think that the
Joker will wind up being the big bill
into the film but it won't start out
that way like there'll be something to
drive Harley Quinn away from the Joker
that over the course of the film Harley
Quinn will come to the realization that
he needs to be stopped and then
eventually by the end of the film she's
victorious but she ends up getting taken
back to Belle Reve or wherever Blackgate
prison or Arkham by Batman what about
continuity though you're asking like
where does this film fit in the timeline
so obviously it'll pick up after the
events of Suicide Squad but if they can
get this movie and Batman started in
time then they can just have the end of
this movie roll into the beginning of
the Batman film but what's gonna happen
next is I'll post my flash video I'll be
talking about who the fastest flash is
like ranking all the members of the
flash family from fastest to slowest
how would I do how'd you do oh I don't
know what do you see for yourself
hold up are you saying I'm faster than
Barry I'm saying at this point in his
training you're faster than your faster
so a lot of you are asking who is the
fastest flash so that video posted
Wednesday morning then I'll post some
Star Wars while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to watch the
trailer for the next episode of the
flash and you can click here for all my
Justice League videos thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you